in a meeting of the g7
nato and the european union are united
to defend our values
freedom democracy and each other's
rights to choose
its own path so thank you again to both
of you for coming and thank you for the
fact that the european union and nato is
standing so strong together so please
usually thank you thank you very much
jens
we are at the watershed moment and
the three of us
standing here together
is yet more proof
of how closely the european union and
nato are responding to the kremlin's
action
the world can see that unity is our
strength
early this morning president putin
ordered atrocious acts
of aggression
against a sovereign and independent
country and innocent people
we will hold russia accountable for this
outrageous violation of ukraine's
sovereignty and the territorial
integrity
and what is at stake is not just on bus
it's not just ukraine
what is at stake is the stability of
europe and the whole international order
our peace order
president putin chose to bring war back
to europe
in a determined and united response the
european union will make it as difficult
as possible for the kremlin to pursue
its aggressive actions
around about 30 minutes ago i had a
phone call with president zelinski he
asked us for whatever the different
stakeholders can do for help
we will later today present a package of
massive and targeted sanctions to
european leaders for their approval
we are coordinated closely with our
partners and allies the united states
the united kingdom canada and norway but
also for example japan and australia
this package will include financial
sanctions that harshly
limit russia's access to the capital
markets
these sanctions will have a heavy impact
russia's economy has already faced
intensive pressure in the recent weeks
and these pressures will now accumulate
these sanctions will suppress russia's
economic growth
increase the borrowing costs raise
inflation intensify capital outflow and
gradually erode its industrial basis
the second main pillar of our sanctions
concerns limiting russia's access to
crucial technology
we want to cut off russia industry
from the technologies desperately needed
today to build a future
our measures will weaken russia's
technology technological position in key
areas actually from which the elite
makes most of their money
and this ranges from high-tech
components to cutting-edge software this
will also seriously degrade the russian
economy in all areas in the future
let me be very clear
it is president putin who will have to
explain this to his citizens
i know
that the russian people do not want this
war
the european union and nato have worked
in close complementarity
and this crisis will bring us even
closer together
it is our shared duty to stand up to the
gravest act of aggression on european
soil since decades
our unity is our best strength
the kremlin understands this very well
and that's why they have tried their
best to divide us but they have achieved
the exact opposite
we are more united
and more determined than ever
we are one union one alliance united in
purpose many things
last night a cataclysm shook europe a
brutal aggression triggered by vladimir
putin and the kremlin against human
beings
a large-scale military attack on the
ukrainian people
and this unprovoked and unjustified
attack is unlike anything on european
soil since the end of the sudden world
war
it is an attack
on the free and sovereign state of
ukraine and its territorial integrity
a blatant violation of international law
replacing rule of law by rule of
brutality
an attack
on peace and security in europe it's
also an attack on the foundations of our
european union a project of peace
prosperity for all europeans
the eu and its member states together
with our allies
will hold russia accountable
the european council will convene today
and will agree in principle on a package
of massive and targeted sanctions
will also decide on political financial
and humanitarian aid for ukraine and its
people
ukraine cities have been hit
innocent people killed
women
men children are fleeing for their lives
they need our strong support more than
ever
we will also discuss the geopolitical
economic and human implication of this
aggression against ukraine and i do not
believe that russian people want war
you do not want to lose young men to a
senseless war with a brother nation
serving as cannon further for an
unjustified unlawful and foolish war
i also appeal to belarus and its people
you have the choice not to follow
russia's destructive action you have the
choice not to take part in this needless
tragedy against your neighbors in
ukraine
and we
the eu stand right solid united firm and
determined together with nato together
with our allies partners and friends to
hold russia accountable to support
ukraine and to protect peace in europe
we stand shoulder to shoulder with all
countries across the world that want to
uphold the
rules-based international order for the
state of peace
thank you
okay we'll go to frankfurt
thanks a lot thomas
um i've got two questions the first one
to the commission president which are
the next practical steps the you can
take to help ukraine cope
with internally displaced
people
and what are the next steps that could
be taken
to also help the neighboring countries
that are probably seeing an influx of
refugees in the next days and weeks
and a question to president michel
when you called the special meeting
yesterday that was certainly before the
attack did you have any indications
yesterday afternoon when you took the
decision to assemble leaders thank you
indeed um we have worked for weeks
to be prepared for the worst to come
hoping for the best but being prepared
for the worst and this was concerning
strengthening
our resilience in the cyber field
making sure that we are independent can
be independent of any kind of pressure
from russian gas supplies we have
reached that stage
and indeed to prepare for potential
refugees
we have with all the frontline member
states now explicit
contingency plans
to welcome and host immediately those
refugees
from ukraine
and what internally displaced people are
concerned we have a lot of support
through echo humanitarian aid shelter
and all the necessities people who are
internally displaced immediately need on
top there will be financial support
increased for ukraine on top of the 1.2
billion macro financial assistance which
is available available right now so the
preparedness
is
fully alerted and
we hope that there will be as little as
possible refugees but we are fully
prepared for them and they are welcome
we had indeed indications that the
situation was dramatically deteriorated
on the ground but we didn't know that
such
an aggression a military invasion a full
steel military invasion would take place
during the last night
okay um
npr
and deutsche welle thank you very much
um to all three of you
ukraine is now under attack because it
wanted to come closer to your
institutions this is why it was attacked
first maidan and then over its its wish
to join nato um and yet all of your
appeals for dialogue have fallen on on
deaf ears
we saw the build up happen
nothing you did worked
what more could you have done and and
how do you feel today when you are
sitting here saying innocent lives are
going to be lost
and these are people who whose only
crime even in the in the words of the
kremlin are that they wanted to be
closer to europe thanks
well i think it's
very important to remember that there is
one
that is the aggressor one
one state that is responsible for what
is happening now in ukraine and that is
russia
russia is the
country which is responsible for the
loss of lies
and aggressive actions against
ukraine
and we have reached out for russia to
russia for many many uh years actually
uh and especially during the last months
to engage in political dialogue to try
to prevent this conflict but at the same
time we are as usual and said we have
also been uh
absolutely prepared for the worst well
and that's what's happening now so
uh
we have to remember that one aggression
that's russia and russia is responsible
for what we see evolving in ukraine now
there are
this there's a process to join the
european union and since many years
we're working with ukraine and we have
gone far ukraine has reached quite uh
quite a substantial progress
if you compare it to
years ago
to really have
the the closeness to the european union
at our eyes
we have a free trade agreement with
ukraine
this is a privileged access to the
european single market and increasing
integration of the ukrainian market into
the single european single market we are
strongly supporting financially in the
case of reforms that are necessary
without any doubt
in ukraine but also strategic
investments in ukraine in a broad set of
fields
we are very intensively working on the
energy security of ukraine over the last
years we have basically been able to
guarantee the energy security of ukraine
through reverse flow for example of gas
but also investing massively in
building up a renewable sector right now
ukraine is decoupling its electricity
grid from the russian electricity grid
and we stand ready to support them in
case that there are any kind of
difficulties this is not easy this is
not trivial this is much earlier than we
had planned but this shows that there's
an enormous amount of support for our
friends in ukraine
and we'll go to interface ukraine
thank you anna interfax ukraine irina
summer secretary general uh don't you
think that if in
bucharest
ukraine got
invitation to join nato nothing will
happen like what we have today
and the question for your leadership
when we are talking about political
support can we talk about perspective of
membership at least political decision
thank you
but again we have to remember who is
responsible
what we
made clear in
bucharest in 2008 and what nato allies
are making again and again is that every
nation has the right to choose some path
and that we support ukraine in their
aspirations to
uh further uh integrate with the
euro-atlantic community and also their
aspirations for membership and then it
is for ukraine to decide whether they
would like to belong to nato and then
this is for 30 allies to decide
on the question of membership and when
ukraine is ready to join
that is our right to the to decide
russia has not right to the to attack
use violence used to
use
their armed forces to invade
an independent sovereign nation
regardless what they think about nato
membership because that's not the excuse
whatsoever
to use military force against a neighbor
that's just not the world we like to
live in where big powers as sercia uses
military force to try to coerce other
countries and if they don't act as they
want to actually invade them and that's
what we're seeing now
we recognize the eu aspiration of
ukraine you know this is a decision that
needs to be taken by the member states
but it's very clear that the last years
we have worked a lot it was described by
the point of the commission in order to
strengthen all the ties with ukraine we
have entered to train to implement
reforms they made a lot of progress more
economic relationships more economics in
different fields and it will be decision
tonight i deliver the european council
to have a debate about the way we will
support
ukraine in different fields the
political field included thank you
thank you very much
[Music]
you